شفيق شفوقي هل انت بخير ربما سانام لمده
عام او اكثر
ايقظوني بعد موتي
سبونج بوب يبدو شفيق مكتئبا
يعني يعطيني شخصيه معينه
ويعني عجبت ناس واجده بعدها نشوف الاصوات
مثلا جانب الكرتوني اكثر نشوف الشخصي
[موسيقى]
العمر 25
مقلد اصواتهم
بدايه صغيره نحب نقلدها
واستمريت في العمل هذا من مسلسل الثعلب
والوعد معانا استاذ
في المسح الوطني
[موسيقى]
الكواليس التسجيل في المسلسل المسموع
ونزلت على الصفحات الاجتماعي فانا اعجاب
ناس واجد يعني تفاجات في المتابعين والناس
بصير بشكل عام من رده فعله مع المحتوى
للصوت جدا
يعني
فيديو عفوي كوميدي وخدي اعجاب ناس واجده
يعني من ناحيه العفويه اللي فيه من ناحيه
الشغل
[موسيقى]
الفيديو جاب اثنين مليون ونص مشاهده على
صفحه تيك توك خلال شهر
فهذا ليش
الصوت واني نحتفل
ونحاول نتقن شخصيات اكثر حاليا شخصيات
سبونج بوب وميكي ماوس اكثر شخصيات تدري
كرتونيه يعني نحاول يعني نقدم بها زي
السكيتشات الصوتيه زي الحلقه بنات
الشخصياتي يعني
حواريه مع بعضهم يعني المسلسل الكرتوني
الصوتي ونحاول يعني شنو نضيف نضيف حوارات
من عندي يعني او نضبط بشكل معين من عندي
نظيف يعني حاجه من عندي مثلا سبونج بوب
شفيق بسيط
اغلب الشخصيه يعني مش كل الكرتون يعني
فهمتني ربما لمده عام او اكثر
نحاول اني شنو يعني نكون يعني محترف
الشهيد يعني نشتغل عليه الصوت نشتغل
الشخصيات عده الشخصيات نحاول اننا نحتفل
فيه يعني
عادي جدا فالمجال اللي حبيته ونشتغل عليه
تمثيل بدايه
في الكليه اسكتشات في القاعه
عجبوني الطلبه وشجعوني اكثر بعد انتقلت
المسرح من ناحيه التمثيل يعني
[موسيقى]
اشتغلت
التمثيل الصامت شركه دي في العراق في
المهرجان الدولي السليمانيه كردستان
العام الماضي
واشتغلت على المسرح الكليه الاداب على
المساحه الوطني
[موسيقى]
مواجهه صعوبه نوعا ما عدت من ناحيه يعني
التصوير والاماكن اللي مثلا نقدم فيها
العضو الاغلبيه نشتغل فيه في المسرح يعني
وجدت صعوبه حتى في
نصوره
اجتماعي يعني تبديل مع احد مصور معاك وكذا
طبي يعني
[موسيقى]
تقليد الاصوات الفتله الاخيره لكن يعني
حسيتها شيء يعني
يعني نحن بنشتغل يعني حبيت فهمت
والتمثيل نفس الشيء كلهن يعني
على الاطلاق وله قلب كبير ويعطف على كل
الكائنات
[موسيقى]